esta es una pregunta abierta de un
examen de economía dice la utilidad y la
elasticidad del precio de la demanda son
conceptos importantes para explicar la
teoría del consumidor hasta aquí todo
bien ahora se nos pide definir la
utilidad marginal antes de que lo
hagamos juntos pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en lo que quiere decir que
entienden por utilidad marginal intenten
escribirlo porque eso es de hecho lo que
tienen que hacer en un examen ap ya
hablamos de la utilidad marginal con
mayor profundidad en otros vídeos pero
si van a presentar este examen tienen
que escribir algo así como es el
beneficio o ganancia o satisfacción
adicional que se obtiene de una unidad
más de algún bien me parece que esa es
una buena definición simplificada de la
utilidad marginal la palabra marginal
hace referencia a cuánta ganancia o
satisfacción vamos a obtener de una
unidad adicional de una cosa no del
total sino sólo de la cantidad adicional
que vamos a tener de una cosa pasemos al
inciso b la siguiente tabla muestra las
los precios y las utilidades marginales
de dos bienes caramelos y café que
mariana compra y en la tabla vemos que
mariana compra 10 kilos de caramelos y 7
kilos de café los caramelos cuestan 2
pesos por kilo y el café cuesta 4 pesos
por kilo entonces la utilidad marginal
del último kilo de caramelos es de 12 y
20 para el café esto es interesante
porque podemos observar que la utilidad
marginal no tiene unidades tiende a no
tener unidades solo son unidades de
utilidad marginal porque lo más
importante es establecer una comparación
entre el primer kilo y el segundo kilo
no estos valores absolutos y todavía no
leo esto pero sospecho que vamos a usar
estos datos de alguna manera en la
siguiente parte de esta pregunta
marianna gasta todo su dinero y compra
sólo estos dos bienes para maximizar su
utilidad debe comprar más caramelos y
menos café comprar más café y menos
caramelos o mantener su consumo actual
muy bien tal vez nuestra respuesta
inmediata sería que basta con echar un
vistazo a cuánta
ganancia o satisfacción obtiene del
siguiente kilo de café en comparación
con el siguiente quiero de caramelos
resulta claro que 20 es mayor que 12 y
entonces podríamos concluir que mariana
debería comprar más café pero esa sería
una respuesta equivocada para entender
por qué vamos a poner otro ejemplo si la
utilidad marginal de un rolls-royce es
mayor que la utilidad marginal de una
fresa y usamos esta misma lógica de solo
comparar directamente las utilidades
marginales deberíamos comprar siempre
más rolls royce y menos fresas
aquí la idea básica es que lo importante
es la utilidad marginal por peso gastado
o sea la utilidad marginal dividida
entre el precio entonces si una fresa
podría competir con un rolls-royce en
cuanto a utilidad marginal eso es
exactamente lo que tenemos que hacer
aquí y en una prueba como el examen ap
definitivamente tenemos que demostrar
que sabemos cómo resolver estos
problemas
entonces para calcular la utilidad
marginal entre el precio de los
caramelos tomamos
la utilidad del último kilo que es
indicativa de la utilidad del siguiente
kilo esto va a ser igual a 12 dividido
entre 2 pesos lo cual nos va a dar 6
luego hacemos el cálculo para el café la
utilidad marginal dividida entre el
precio es igual a 20 dividido entre 4 lo
cual nos va a dar 5 vamos a encerrar en
un círculo este resultado y podemos
decir que mariana debe comprar más
caramelos para maximizar su utilidad
porque su utilidad marginal por peso es
mayor que la del café y con eso
terminamos nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo